welcome to the first session of
lightning talks on fairness in ai
systems i am amit sharma senior
researcher at microsoft research in
india and i'll be your host
these short talks will give you an
overview of the work on fairness and ai
systems at microsoft
the speakers will highlight how they've
been using and applying fairness
principles in real world ai systems in
particular we will look at measuring and
mitigating different kinds of fairness
related harms
in vision speech to text and natural
language systems
with that please welcome michael amuako
and kristen lard to kick us off
i'm kristin laird joined by michael
imoko and we're both responsible ai
program managers at microsoft
in this talk we'll talk a little bit our
approach to fairness and then we'll talk
about how we're trying to develop
products responsibly and enable
customers to use them responsibly
both michael and i are from cognitive
services which offers pre-built ai
models that range from vision to speech
to language to decision but in this talk
we're going to focus on our
speech-to-text service specifically
there are several ways of thinking about
responsible ai and microsoft has a very
comprehensive approach that covers six
different principles
but one of the ways that we've been
breaking this down in cognitive services
is into two buckets
how do we develop our products
responsibly so what sorts of fairness
assessments and mitigations do we need
to do
and how can we enable customers to use
them responsibly by being transparent
communicating characteristics
and in some cases making certain
technology limited access
specifically within responsible
development fairness is one of our top
priorities
there are different types of fairness
related harms that we consider but one
of the most salient for speech to text
is quality of service which measures
whether or not the service performs as
well for some people as it does for
others
when we're considering quality of
service fairness there are several steps
involved
first we need to identify the priority
factors and groups
where a factor is something like age
gender or nationality and the groups are
the subgroups within that factor so with
gender for example it may be men women
non-binary and other gender identities
next we assess for fairness related
harms based on our testing and careful
data collection do we notice any
disparities that we then need to
mitigate
it's also important to reassess on a
regular cadence and make this just part
of engineering excellence
but the process is only complete if we
also communicate some of those
characteristics and limitations which
ties into the responsible development
practices that michael is going to talk
about
currently our speech service tests a
variety of factors and groups ranging
from different languages to genders to
different ages to different accents and
nationalities
and we're on a continual journey to
improve as this particular study
highlighted and this became one of our
top priorities
as we considered how to apply our
quality of service approach it became
clear that we needed to design our data
set and our test sets extremely
carefully and go back to the drawing
board to consider
what are all of the different factors
that may impact the way in which
somebody speaks
so there are variety of different
factors that impact speech ranging from
age to geography and when we think about
designing a data set for fairness
assessment
we need to consider both confirmatory
factors and exploratory factors
a confirmatory factor is one where we
already know
that that factor impacts performance and
we have to prioritize certain
distributions for that in the data
collection
an exploratory factor might be something
where we don't have evidence yet that it
impacts performance
but we hypothesize that it might so we
still want to collect at least some
metadata about that factor so we can
incorporate it into our analysis and our
troubleshooting and potentially
prioritize it in future data collections
as we went through our own data
collections we've had a variety of
learnings one of them was the difference
between some of our expectations and
reality
we went into some of these data
collections knowing that it was
important to have careful design
and it still turned out that we needed
even more expert input and community
input than we initially expected
for this data set it turned out to be
crucial to have expert input ranging
from sociolinguists to fairness experts
to community members but designing the
collection is only half the story it's
also important to consider how we
actually conduct the collection
and getting that expert input which is a
best practice we highly recommend
impacted everything from the tasks that
participants saw to the screening to
even how we messaged them
so that's a high level overview of just
some of our fairness responsible
development practices and i'll turn it
over to michael for responsible use
thanks kristin um so as kristin
mentioned i'll be talking about
responsible use
of ai
starting with responsible ai
documentation
so a big part of how we
try to help our customers use our
services responsibly
is by including documentation
that outlines the different guidelines
for for using a service
and so that ranges from use cases and
key considerations
to things related to privacy and
security
beyond documentation we also aim to
offer tools that customers can use to
understand fairness in their own context
the specific tool that i'll be
discussing is called fair learn
which offers
algorithms and methods to
do a disaggregated analysis
of a service or system
and in this
case i'll be doing a walkthrough of a
speech service for example
so one of the first things to think
about and
i'm sort of using fair learn or using a
fairness assessment tool is the data
so in a speech data set there'll
typically be a common passage that the
readers are instructed to read
and there will be metadata that includes
things like age native language country
and as the person performing the
assessment you're choosing which of this
metadata you want to assess fairness
along
so in this example i'm showing results
on
countries
and so here we're looking at raw word
area values and so each of the values
are positive
and the passage itself is what has been
compared to the output of a specific
system
but i also wanted to note that typically
you should compare the human annotation
of the speech to the predicted
text and that way
you're fully capturing what the speaker
said
as compared to the prediction
and another way to think about this is
in terms of disparity from a chosen
benchmark
so
for this example i use 0.5 as the
benchmark and that's why you'll notice
that some of the values are negative
meaning that they're below this
benchmark
and some of the values are positive
meaning that they're above that
benchmark
and this could be another useful way to
think about fairness
lastly on this within fairlane you can
think about data distribution
which can give you some insight into how
reliable each of the results are
um so in this dataset for example we had
majority english speakers and so that's
where we might have the most reliable
results versus smaller groups might have
less reliable results in terms of the
values
so other things to consider are
combinations of features so if you were
to look at country and age for example
you might get some different insights
consider thinking about whether it might
make sense to compare a word error rate
against some chosen benchmark as opposed
to comparing the raw values
and also consider the role of the data
distribution
so overall in terms of considerations
for both us at microsoft and our users
it's important to carefully think about
data set design and the factors that
you're looking to
consider in the collection
it's important to seek input as kirsten
mentioned not just from subject matter
experts
but also from members of the relevant
demographic groups
it's important to assess and communicate
the limitations of the system
and ultimately to make responsible ai
part of the engineering life cycle and
as i said these are our key learnings
and insights and thank you guys again
for attending our talk
hi my name is solem brocus and i'm a
principal researcher at microsoft
research today i'll be presenting some
joint work with colleagues at microsoft
research on representational harms and
image tagging
specifically when computer vision models
are used to automatically tag images
computer vision is used for image
tagging across a range of applications
for example microsoft uses it to
automatically generate alt text and
powerpoint textual descriptions of
images for blind and low vision users
there's also increasingly common feature
in photo management software which
allows users to search by keyword even
when they have not manually annotated
photos themselves
over the past few years however there
have been growing concerns about these
applications and the harms that they
might cause
this research attempts to catalog the
potential harm's image tagging systems
and we provide concrete examples of each
type of harm considering the measurement
and mitigation techniques that might
help to identify and address them
work builds on previous research in
which we drew a distinction between
allocational and representational harms
allocational harms are the traditional
focus of research on fairness and
machine learning where researchers tend
to worry about
the way that machine learning might
affect access to important opportunities
in resources such as jobs admissions to
university or loans
in contrast representational harms occur
when the behavior of a machine learning
model affects the understanding beliefs
and attitudes that people hold about
specific social groups for example when
professor sophia noble demonstrated in
her book algorithms of oppression
that image search results included
pornographic content for the query of
black girls but not white girls
we argue that such model behavior is
harmful because it reproduces unjust
social hierarchies in which members of
certain groups are cast as subordinate
or less worthy of respect than others
we caution against reducing concerns
with fairness in the context of computer
vision to mere disparities in model
performance across groups or to
instances of model behavior that happens
to offend a particular individual
in our work we are concerned with the
with image tagging that systematically
affects people's understanding of
specific social groups and as a result
these groups standing in society
in referral paper we outline six
distinct representational harms in image
tagging but given my limited time i
won't be able to go into depth about all
of them
i do want to discuss a few and offer
some key takeaways however
first i want to show how our taxonomy
helps to highlight the fact that
different harms call for different
measurements and
mitigation techniques consider
stereotyping as a distinct harm
you might think that we can capture such
harm by examining differences in the
error rates for similar images
containing members of different groups
for example we might want to investigate
the degree to which image tagging
systems incorrectly tag women doctors as
nurses
and ensure that the accuracy of such
classifications does not vary regardless
of the gender of the person in the image
that said we might also want to examine
whether images that we perceive to be
the same but only varying the identity
of the people who appear in them do not
receive a different distribution of tags
even if those tags are strictly accurate
researchers have shown that images the
image tagging systems are more likely to
remark on women's physical appearance
while men are more likely to receive
tags describing their occupation
now let's consider cases where image
type insistence might be demeaning
obvious cases
include the use of explicit racial
epithets cases actually that researchers
have shown on a number of occasions
but cases of demeanor behavior can be
more subtle as when a system returns the
tag halloween costume for an image of a
native american headdress
while there's nothing inherently
objectionable about the tag halloween
costume in comparison to a racial
epithet
the application of this tag halloween
costume to this particular image is
demeaning because it trivializes the
native dress of the american indians
identifying and anticipating
uh demeaning behavior is much more
challenging and much more open-ended
because it requires considerable
cultural and historical understanding
our taxonomy also helps to reveal that
some obvious mitigations for certain
harms may be in tension with another
for example some harms are caused by the
inclusion of certain tags while others
are caused by their absence
the first two harms in our taxonomy
focus on the harms caused by the
imposition of identity categories onto
people given their appearance gender
classification for example assumes that
gender is always visually evident that
there's a clear and consistent mapping
between visual appearance and gender and
that gender can be unproblematically
assigned to people without their
knowledge consent or participation
such practices raise concerns about the
freedom that people have to self-define
and the degree to which membership in
certain social groups is assumed to
require a certain appearance
and thus we might hope to mitigate that
harm by refusing to engage in gender for
classification at all
at the same time the failure to
explicitly name the groups that have
suffered some injustice due to the
membership in a particular group can be
harmful as well
tagging the final image for example with
people and walking fails to acknowledge
the unique struggle faced by women and
suffragists in this case avoiding the
harm requires naming the group whose
identity is at stake
our work highlights that different harms
call for different measurement and
mitigation techniques and that any
mitigation technique developed to
address one harm may unless with taking
with care exacerbate another
thanks very much
hi i'm chad atala today i'm going to be
talking about savvy a method for
measuring fairness related harms in
natural language services
so first things first we need to get
some background let's talk about
fairness and language models
language models are based on text
written by humans and societal biases
are inherent to human language
so naturally those biases are reflected
in the text data sets
then we take those data sets and train
language models on them and the models
internalize that unfair behavior
now it's one thing to have a unfair
model sitting in a silo but what's
happening increasingly these days is
large companies taking large language
models and building natural language
services think something along the lines
of a service completing your sentences
while you're writing an email
now when that happens we have real users
interacting with these models
and
that unfair behavior can cause real
psychological harm to those users
now this is a very serious problem and
we need to address it
so how do we approach addressing these
fairness related harms
we typically need to identify the harms
and the patterns we need to measure
and then we need to mitigate the measure
and mitigate side of these things is
very familiar to natural language
service practitioners and
language model developers
but
the tricky part here is that we're
dealing with a socio-technical problem
this problem really straddles the human
experience and the technological aspect
behind language models so the measure
step is actually lacking
good prior methods
we need to come up with a new solution
so what we need to do to design a good
solution is take the best of both worlds
from the computer science and the social
science side of things
from the computer science side we like
some principles from test sets and unit
testing from the social science side we
really need to borrow that user-centric
framing thinking about the humans who
are at the other end of the service and
can be caused this psychological harm we
need to protect them and center on them
then measurement modeling measurement
modeling acknowledges that when we
create metrics for a theoretical
construct we're really making a proxy
and the measurement modeling lens asks
practitioners questions about whether
your proxy is reliable and valid
so given
those best of both world
inspirations to draw upon we come up
with five principles for savvy
scalable automated
valid
interpretable and inclusive
scalable because we are borrowing that
user-centric framing and when
the same language model is served under
the hood in different products but the
different product scenarios have
slightly different user experiences we
actually need to create
unique tailored solutions for
measurements in each of those scenarios
then automated when the resulting
measurement is created we need the
practitioners to be able to quickly
decide if model a or model b is going to
minimize risk of harm for their users
then valid this revisits the measurement
modeling lens when you created that
proxy to measure fairness or
stereotyping
did you do it well is the resulting
measurement actually approximating this
harm and measuring what you intend it to
interpretable means that we're going to
avoid using black box machine learning
to measure furnace related harms in our
other black box language models and
inclusive here is the most important it
means that unless we as practitioners
collect the lived experiences and
document the lived experiences of all
possible people who could interact with
this system we are going to be excluding
certain marginalized groups not
accounting for them in our measurements
and mitigations and furthering the
fairness related harms to those groups
of people so we need to include and
center on those individuals when we are
creating our measurements
so that brings us to the savvy process
the savvy process from a bird's eye view
is lifting
transferring and discussing
when we lift we combine the identified
harms and patterns of harms that we've
taken from those inclusive conversations
with users with the product expertise
understanding how the models work under
the hood and how the user experience
flows
then we lift
and we transfer we transfer into
building a data set building a scoring
mechanism and a metric for the product
side
then we have to go back to the social
lens and discuss the measurement
modeling validity and reliability
by leveraging the best of both worlds
here practitioners can create
well-principled measurements that
protect users from natural language
service harms thank you